les derniers feux du campement gilet
jaune de lui ce matin des employés
municipaux ont démonté la cabane de
palettes
le lieu était désert au début de
l'opération avant qu'une dizaine de
manifestants ne vienne constater de
leurs propres yeux le démantèlement de
leurs camps qu'ils savent est imminent
préfecture et justice ayant jugé leurs
installations illégales parce que ça en
termes de détermination bas non du tout
le qg c'est un lieu où on se réunissait
où on donnait des à fond mais même sans
lieu salon tam pas sans atouts les
gilets jaunes là au contraire je pense
que ça va même être pire
en saône et loire c'était un symbole
pour les gilet jaune le dernier
campement encore debout le 22 novembre
dernier ils prenaient possession de ce
bout de terrain en bordure de
départementale 3 mois et demi plus tard
le maire a procédé au démantèlement en
accord avec le propriétaire et le
locataire du terrain
il avance des raisons de sécurité l'
alerte météo au vent violent lui faisait
redouter des chutes d'objets sur la
chaussée il ne cache pas non plus une
certaine exaspération qui était monté au
fil des semaines on était solidaires des
gilets jaunes puisque leurs
revendications étaient légitimes
aujourd'hui on est tombé sur un camp où
on était là pour faire la fête pour
nuire à l'environnement
des feux d'artifice et des pétards de la
musique l'alcool qui vient là dessus je
pense maintenant nous donnerons dit stop
au bout de trois mois de pressions
diverses et variées des menaces de la
part de certains gilet jaune et
la pression que j'aide barber aux
autorités publiques et aux autorités de
la justice pour moi c'est un très grand
soulagement
j'espère seulement que ce sera le
dernier épisode et qui aura pas un acte
2 en ce qui me concerne le propriétaire
des lieux a fait installer des barrières
pour éviter toute récidive sous peine de
poursuites pénales
les gilet jaune de la région chalonnaise
quant à eux se réunissent ce soir pour
envisager la suite de leur mouvement